[Music]
let's talk about mainstream western
culture um
do you think it's time to move on from
alcohol you know we've become secular
supposedly is it time to leave our
our roots in wine and move on to better
pastures
well of course it is i mean
we kind of thought we were there in the
60s but um
but there was something called a
backlash and of course and that again
yeah the war on drugs the war on drugs
wasn't war on drugs it was a war on
people who voted against the republicans
and who might have taken drugs they
couldn't ban voting unlike in russia
where they can now but but they in those
days you know they had to find something
to ban to sort of vilify the people who
were against the war in vietnam etc so
so drugs
and and people who use drugs other than
alcohol are very often
less interested in voting
than people who don't so you know but
they're an easy target because if you
know they they
uh they're easy to hate they're easy to
punish you can put them in prison and
they don't vote anyway so they're not
gonna change the rules so so yeah so you
know we we have to
look at the last 50 years history
really it all started to go wrong when
the americans
made alcohol legal again in 1933 after
prohibition
you know and and it's a very it was a
seminal moment in the whole
kind of philosophy of what to do about
drugs because for two reasons the first
is that alcohol prohibition had kind of
failed at one level it had obviously
failed because uh in terms of
economically it failed it failed because
of the the rise of the organized crime
in the mafia it was actually a success
it's another level it was a success
intellectually because it it proved that
prohibition didn't work but no one
learned that lesson
because we carried on then prohibiting
other things and discovering that they
didn't work either but but as soon as
soon as alcohol was made legal in the
states the this huge army the
untouchables the 35 000 feds who were
protecting america from alcohol
were unemployed or facing unemployment
so they were the only the guy that was
running them harry anslinger was
confronted with a challenge how does he
keep his job
you know and how does he keep keep these
other people these other his men
employed and
so he invented another problem and he it
was cannabis but no one cared about
cannabis so he renamed it marijuana and
he blamed mexicans and that's a really
great combination you've got foreigners
and a new drug wow that's something we
can all hate and be and the whole
process then of kind of ban drugs and
exterminate drugs that just continued
being propagated in cycles till the
present day i mean anna what do you
think
is it time to move on from alcohol no i
don't think it's
that's exactly the right question um i
don't think it's necessarily it's
absolutely time to move on from mass
produced industrially processed soulless
alcohol absolutely but i don't
necessarily think we have to throw out
the wine with the with the baby with the
bath water and close down all the you
know family-run vineyards or or anything
like that i think the real question
should be is it time to move on from
that unconscious party culture
the problem with alcohol is it's a very
fine line between you know that alcohol
that makes you maybe more conscious and
you know for some people a better
novelist or a better writer to that
tipping point where you're unconscious
and sometimes literally unconscious and
passed out
and then anyone can violate you in any
way they please we need to like stop
teaching our children that that's fun
that that's a good night out
we need to
recreate and socialize
in positive uplifting ways move to a
more conscious
way of socializing and recreating and
partying instead of the unconscious
model i mean of course it goes without
saying that different cultures consume
alcohol even in western europe very very
differently from each other you know the
french are of course raised to have a
small glass from a very young age and
whatnot but i'm curious as to what you
think joanna about sort of the role of
um
say literature in that sort of aspect of
how
we culturally talk about alcohol and
alcohol consumption and you know the
drunk and writer and the alcohol the
depressed alcoholic all that kind of
thing yeah yeah it's so interesting i
was just thinking as anna was speaking
of there's i think it's an old ben elton
sketch about a great night out drunk you
know we could not walk we could not talk
and you sort of think well really was
that a great night so obviously you know
i think paris also said about you know
the doses the poison you know that it's
it's very much a kind of question of
dosing but yes in terms of i guess
literally so if you if you see
everything through the narrow lens of
literatures i keep
clearly i keep doing but i was thinking
in terms of knowing that prohibition
didn't work as again as a reader because
all the novelists are obsessed with
alcohol you know during that period and
you keep wondering why on earth with the
absolute quintessential sort of bible
really being the great gatsby you know
if scott fitzgerald which was published
in 1925 at the height and that sort of
culture which for him was incredibly
damaging and he ended up writing one of
the best crack up stories actually
called the crack up which is about just
when the drugs don't work type thing
when it all kind of falls apart and i
guess in terms of the drinking culture
you know there is a big kind of macho
male sort of thing going on with you
know the sort of writers the kind of
great drunken writers that it's okay for
the men you know like hemingway is
really great because he can you know
down sort of well the entire supply of
alcohol you know before breakfast and
then right but you know the kind of i
think the history of female writers who
enjoy the odd tipple is much less you
know kind of adulatory so there is this
quite interesting again sort of cultural
assumptions within it yeah where is it i
was gonna say as well in terms of moving
on i mean i guess lots of coaches have
moved on islamic culture in the early
medieval period moves on you know the
ayurvedic tradition of meditation
fasting you know that goes to something
else so there are of course you're
asking about western culture so that
that's absolutely right but there are
lots and lots of other cultures where
other forms are trying to be in the
present moment or to explore kind of
recreation you know don't involve
that's really interesting i mean the
last sort of theme was meant to be about
you know what what happens in the in the
future what how do we
let's reimagine this what what are what
intoxicants will we use
um
what would yours be of choice et cetera
et cetera well i'm drinking one now
i mean so that one of the this is called
centia by the way this is a botanical
alternative to alcohol which i've
invented
which is you can get the last few
bottles in the center bar up there
i mean what's remarkable about alcohol
is it hasn't changed in
has never changed it's always been
ethanol
almost every single thing in your life
has changed in fact alcohol maybe the
arc on water but even water comes with
bubbles and and it comes with different
sources but alcohol has been unchanged
in four or five six thousand years why
is that the answer is
because
it's cheap to produce it's
extraordinarily profitable for the
industry
and so there's no impetus and this and
it's
economically very valuable to societies
because of the taxation i'm a doctor i
you know and i know there are other dogs
how many doctors in the audience
yeah
every day all each of you meet someone
who's been damaged either themselves or
their family damaged by alcohol
that's it's alcohol permeates medicine
and all my life in medicine i've been
trying to deal with problems of alcohol
and then about 15 years ago i was
working on the government foresight
program looking at where what the future
could look like we kind of came to the
realization actually we could replace
alcohol we know the science of alcohol
now why don't we just make a safer
alcohol and that's what i've been trying
to do
and it's actually it's not difficult i
mean if one guy by himself pretty much
can do it if the whole industry wanted
to
and about 12 years ago i got over the
chief scientists who may not know this
but all the big
drinks companies they have
science departments in fact
if i can i digress for a second i think
you have biochemistry
sorry
please feel free
the discipline of biochemistry
was invented
by the drinks industry why because the
danes carlsberg couldn't make as good a
pilsner as the germans so they employed
scientists to work out why they couldn't
beat the germans and the scientists said
ah because there's some there's an acid
difference in the water we're using in
denmark compared with germany so they
worked out how to measure acid
acidity that's called ph the guy could
us did invented it and that was
just to make better beer so there's a
there are scientists in all the drinks
companies and i got
one
into imperial and i said look
i could replace alcohol and he said yeah
that's great we all know that
we all know that what we're doing as an
industry is killing people all the
scientists have got this terrible
conflict
and i said great well why don't you go
back and tell your boss you know we'll
work together and replace alcohol and he
said i will and of course he went back
and he came back said and the marketeers
say no there's no money in it
and there isn't because i've got history
the cheapest way of making profit but we
science can do it and we've done it and
here's a botanical alternative which we
believe will reduce
give some of the effects the beneficial
effects of alcohol but it's going to be
much less likely to damage your liver
your heart your brain and give you a
hangover so it can happen
but
what we need is the culture to accept it
and actually to drive it if we if the
same amount of money was put into
replacing alcohol which kills has killed
as many people this year as kobe it has
been put into curing kovid we'd all none
of us would be needing to drink alcohol
next year that the problem would have
been solved in the last year but it
hasn't and it won't be until culturally
we decide that's a big ambition for us
fascinating i mean
you you know a bit more about the
history of humans right so has has there
been
are there any other examples of what
happens when humans suddenly decide to
like change
their food and drink consumptions in
particular i'm thinking about and like
how that change happens i know that's a
really big question that's a huge i mean
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you